let me read uh this next one here if you
want to pull it up right there uh uh
where it's a complete different story
here I'm curious to know what he's going
to say to it and what's your feedback
going to be on this one both of you guys
uh page four where it says a crash of
the U.S housing market is very unlikely
even as mortgage rates search to 14 your
highs markets Insider this is a story
from yesterday pandemic home buying hot
spots like Sacramento and San Jose have
a Thrive over the past few years but as
fears of an economic recession spread
they are now most at risk of facing a
housing downturn according to Redfin if
the U.S does enter a recession we're
unlikely to see a housing market crash
like the Great Recession because the
factors affecting the economy are
different a senior Economist at Redfin
said in a housing report but a recession
or even a continued economic downturn
that doesn't reach recession levels
would impact some local housing markets
more than others read from researchers
looked at several indicators to rank
cities on their chances of a housing
market downturn in the case of U.S
recession the fear in this case is that
as the broader economic Titans some home
values may decline leaving homeowners
holding a mortgage far more than the
value of their investment which do you
guys agree or disagree with this
go ahead
um
it is a fact that if I don't sell my
house and I've got some Equity but on my
street the prices are going down my
available Equity if I go to any lending
institution just went down and so
um do I think it's going to be a crash I
don't think it's going to be a crash but
we just talked about it already I think
the the scissor pinch is already coming
and we're seeing you we're not
speculating on it we're looking at real
data and so crash like 08 no but are we
about to see these these prices go down
and I want to know the motivation of the
author here what point are you trying to
make because there's a conflict in there
because even if the prices go down a
little bit Pat the guy with the equity
now has less home equity to redo the
kitchen and the bathrooms so you don't
have to be in the market to be impacted
by a dimension of values
I get that's totally totally correct and
I think
you know back in 2007 and eight uh chair
fad Bernanke uh would very public in
saying he did not see a problem in
housing even after it started going down
and it made the note that not since a
Great Depression had housing prices on a
national basis ever fallen
at all because uh and it hadn't uh the
only time it fell nationally was in the
Great Depression so that gave them a lot
of comfort that housing was going to
perform much much better than than what
they ever thought and again that turned
out to be a mistake and uh and I think
housing should have fallen 10 to 20
percent nationally it was about that
overvalued in my opinion and it went
more than twice that because the the
they let the liquidity crisis come and
they just went into free fall I don't
think that latter risk is here this time
uh I but I do think that prices could
easily correct in some of these markets
by 10 to 20 percent maybe a little bit
more
um uh but I I don't think I think the
fed and the government will avoid going
into panic mode the way they did last
time and I think they'll make better
decisions and and not cause that hyper
uh fall off hopefully you're right I
mean look the I do want to talk about
rent because a lot of people are also
right now going through the rent
challenges so this is from reason uh
latest inflation numbers show that rent
is too damn High inflation continues to
ravage America's paychecks and it's
increasingly shown up in Rising rents
the latest Consumer Price Index by the
Bureau of Labor Statistics shows that
prices ticked up by another point one
percent for urban consumers in August
for an annualized increase of 8.3 for
the year the marginal increase in
inflation comes in spite of fuel costs
falling uh 10.3 last month increases in
the shelter food and Medical Care uh
indexes were the largest of many
contributors to the broad-based monthly
all items increase at the the BLS and
the News released today the latest CPI
shows 0.7 increases and it continues to
spot rents reported by listing companies
are grown at even a faster rate
apartment list reports a 7.2 percent
increase and rental prices so far for
the year that's a moderate compared to
the 17.6 percent increase in rent the
company reported in 2021 it's still well
above pre-pandemic increases from 3.4
percent and 2.3 percent in 18 and 19. is
this gonna come back down or is this
going to stay steady when it comes down
to in regards to rents well rents have
have a rising well you know at at a high
level but they still do not reflect
what's gone on in the pricing of overall
housing now the rents haven't increased
as fast as the price of housing
nationally so you're going to have a
catch-up where rents are going to keep
going up unless how you know but house
if housing prices start to fall off then
you'll see a moderation in the uh in the
rent you know and the other thing that's
going on in our country is that
individual homeowners are increasingly
getting squeezed out of the markets so
more and more of the housing units are
getting purchased in bulk by investors
and those are then in turn are being
rented now that um and and that'll be
interesting to see what kind of returns
that is you know maybe the the guy's
doing that now are kind of buying at the
peak and it may may not work for them
too well from that standpoint but the uh
but as a country it uh if if we start
getting more and more of the units uh
into rental and fewer and fewer people
able to own homes over time again that
ability to amass
equity and the American dream and all
the kind of things that housing has
traditionally provided for average
income people is is going to go away and
right now again affordability of housing
is is the worst in in some decades so
it's gonna we're gonna see immediately
that fewer and fewer people can get in
and actually afford board and to buy
houses and all that until until these
prices correct somewhat so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]